et pour en parler nous sommes avec
gildas mahé patron du restaurant carré
français à rome bonsoir gildas mahé
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france le ciel qui s'éclaircit enfin
pour vous aussi en italie et encore plus
avec événement de cet euro de football
les clients seront au rendez vous vous
êtes en tout cas soulager de voeux cette
période qui s'ouvre alors nous nous
sommes soulagés surtout de des progrès
qui ont été faits en matière de
réouverture et 2 est de retour de la
clientèle qui s'est pas fait attendre et
le rôle euros et 1 est un élément mais
qui est même secondaire par rapport à la
à ce qu'on constate au quotidien c'est
que dès qu'on a pu retrouver un peu d
espace de liberté les romains les
italiens se sont précipités pour
retrouver dans leurs anciennes habitudes
de plus en termes touristiques en plus
des italiens qui sont ravis de retrouver
leurs terrasses comment vous gérez cela
on imagine qu'il ya quand même des
restrictions sanitaires on est c'est
très suivi d'italie et c'est pour ça que
c'est d'ailleurs souvent des faux procès
qui sont faits du point de vue français
aux italiens c'est que les
l'administration italienne est très
pointilleuse les contrôles sont
fréquents et évidemment que les
professions liées au tourisme sont
heureuses de s'adapter aux obligations
pour pouvoir poursuivre une croissance
qui se dément pas nous on al'avantage
dans mon établissement d'être un
établissement de grands espaces
puisqu'on à 1000 mètres carrés
donc on n'a pas eu trop de difficultés à
créer des surfaces qui permettent à tout
le monde
profitez en sécurité d'un café ou d'un
déjeuner ou d'un dîner avec nous sans
match de foot ce qu'on a créé en fait un
espace dédié pour ça isolée du reste du
restaurant alors en france il ya le
passé ni terre qui a été voté qui entre
en vigueur donc qui est entrée en
vigueur depuis hier le 9 juin
est ce que c'est le cas également en
italie sachant qu'en france et pour les
événements de plus de 2000 personnes est
ce que vous on parle de passes annie
terre notamment pour accéder au
restaurant c'est quelque chose qui a
vite été écartée
pas pour les restaurants s'était
heureusement vite écartée en revanche
pour les discothèques c'est en
discussion et les discussions sont
houleuses je vous le cache pas faut
parler des professions du monde de la
nuit qui ont tellement souffert que le
pass annie terre étant encore en fait
une théorie dont on connaît pas les
normes applicative
quand on doit monter une affaire et
résiste économiquement ce quelque chose
qui reste de l'or de la théorie c'est
pas facile quand il faut recruter quand
il faut manager quand il faut acheter
provisionné donc en italie on en parle
du passé ni terre il a été voté comme
dans le reste de l'europe son
applicabilité est encore à définir
on parle du 1er juillet en attendant on
continue en fait à faire très attention
au quotidien mais le camp le pass
arrivera on saura s'adapter
c'est vrai qu'à une forme d'euphorie en
france également avec les beaux jours
les terrasses il n'empêche un lot et
metz joue un peu les trouble fêtes en
disant que pour le moment la vaccination
n'empêchera pas la résurgence de
l'épidémie
ça vous fait peur justement ce côté
voilà le vent de liberté son fléau on
ouvre les vannes on en oublie le virus
est ce que ça peut être à double
tranchant selon vous alors oui ça peut
être à double tranchant parce que je
vous cache pas que tous les âges et tous
les indices vont dans le bon sens selon
nous on le constate dans notre
établissement à rome
on a retrouvé les sur les neuf premiers
jours de juin 2021
là la même population la même
fréquentation qu'en 2019 on a même
progressé
je vous le cache pas de 15% donc c'est
on est on est on est assez heureux 2-2
2 de sa qui s'inscrit d'ailleurs sur le
sérum et aux mairies de toutes les
innovations de toutes les adaptations
qu'on a fait pendant le lock donne où on
a créé de nouveaux services et en fait à
la fin c'est le cumul de tous ces
services qui font qu'on progresse par
rapport à 2019
la confiance des ménages et la confiance
de l'industrie dans la reprise est là
puisque ça progresse tous les indices en
fait sont fournies par l'équivalent du
medef accepte la confindustria détermine
que la confiance est au rendez-vous et
chaque semaine ça progresse
simplement il y a un effet qui qui
inquiète c'est l'éventualité d'une
quatrième vague
si celle ci devait donner lieu à de
nouvelles mesures administratives
tous ces effets bénéfiques qu'on
constate s'écroulerait du jour au
lendemain en italie avant cela peut-être
qu'il ya ailleurs à l'accalmie de l'été
vous attendez
encore plus de touristes les conditions
sont simples par exemple pour venir en
italie quelles sont les règles
aujourd'hui en italie c'est très simple
présenter un pcr et contrairement à
votre arrivée en france un quart d'heure
après votre descente d'avion
vous êtes déjà prêts à partir dans le
centre de rome
merci en tout cas à gildas mahé patron
du restaurant carré français d'avoir été
avec nous et bonne reprise donc merci à
vous